et voilà comme ça c'est réparé bravo
françois c'est parfait tu peux monter
ses solides tient pas là casimir
bonjour tout le monde
bonjour casino où vas-tu comme ça vous
avez devant vous le plus grand pilote
d'avion de l'îlot z'enfants quoi tu
plaisantes n'est pas du tout monsieur
beauchesne avait dans son hangar un
vieil avion alors nous l'avons remis en
état et je décolle dans moins d'une
heure cette fois que gémir tu dépasse
les bornes
tu ne peux absolument pas décollé avec
cet avion qui n'a jamais piloté un avion
de ta vie mais c'est très facile
monsieur bush elle m'a tout expliqué les
françois dit qu'elle te sens tu fais
quelque chose d'unique c'est dangereux
gilles est inquiète pas mais c'est
sûrement une farce et femmes
et ben c'est histoire de face moi ça ne
rend malade
donc je préfère m'en allais d'accord on
occupe idiot mais qu'est ce qui lui
prend à les douves du fort là mais
casimir tu sais très bien que julie se
fait beaucoup de souci pour toi ô ming a
vraiment pas de quoi
mathieu beauchesne a tout expliqué c'est
vraiment très facile pourquoi monsieur
beauchesne devient-il pas avec toi à
bien mathieu beauchesne et n'est plus
tout à fait jeune et puis il m'a dit
qu'il avait le mal de l'air
casimir c'est quand même très risqué
c'est très dangereux les pilotes de
l'air lui même mais des années avant de
piloter tout seul un avion on dirait que
tu n'as pas confiance en moi non enfin
si au début tout va bien où j'en suis
moi parce que tout à fait entre nous
j'aimerais bien pouvoir venir avec toi
c'est vrai
oh oui piloter un avion c'est mon rêve
le faire a décollé en douceur comme ça
la clv dix mois dans les airs virée sur
l'aisne
passer à travers un nuage regarder la
mer donc garder les montagnes et puis le
retour atterrir en souplesse comme ça là
rien dans laxe à la quelle merveille de
volée alors tu viens avec moi
et ben non casimir malheureusement je ne
peux pas imaginer que je lis apprennent
que je suis venu avec toi mais serait
furieuse puis surtout elle se ferait
deux fois plus de soucis oui j'imagine
quelle tristesse cela va être pour toi
quand tu vas me voir décoller tout ça
tout à l'heure quand veux tu il faut
choisir dans la vie et oui mais quand
même casimir je préférerais que dieu
quelqu'un à côté de toi tu serais plus
en sécurité
bah oui moi aussi mais mais qui qui qui
j'aperçois monsieur du snob qui arrive
casimir ci lui proposer de t'accompagner
ça c'est une idée françois mes très
chers amis que le choix de vous voir
bonjour mais c'est du cynisme bourget
j'ai une proposition à vous faire
quel est cet accoutrement ce n'est
pourtant pas carnaval voyons mais c'est
du snob les émirs va piloter un avion
quoi de 6,1 de ses aéroplan kiki
pétaradant le ciel et qui sentent le
cambouis en quelque chose horrible
j'avais pensé que vous pourriez
m'accompagner pardon faux sac
qu'at-il dit que c'était bien entendu
c'est des snobs et casimir vous propose
de faire votre baptême de l'air c'est
formidable lellouche à fond sans jamais
de la vie je mettrai en plaidant dans
cet engin pareil je pensais quand les
gens de votre qualité savait tout faire
et n'avait peur de rien peut-être mais
ils ont aussi le droit de choisir leur
sport et le mieux c'est le golf
miniature
vous me décevez beaucoup moi votre place
monsieur les snobs je vous assure que je
ne refuserai pas mais mais je vous en
prie françois les i avec casimir
j'aurais bien aimé monsieur d'histoire
mais je ne peux pas je me demande ce
qu'on a pensé julie quand elle saura que
vous refusez de faire votre baptême de
l'air
elle va être déçu je suis même sûr
qu'elle ne vous adressera plus jamais la
parole tu es sûr que ça certains c'est
très ennuyeux parce que je n'ai pas du
tout envie de monter dans cette aéroplan
et d'autres parlent
l'idée de décevoir mes demoiselles julie
mais m'est insupportable
bon très bien j'accepte et je ne monte
pas dans cet arrêt au plein sens un
parachute
vous aurez votre parachute j'en mets
moi-même 4 d'ailleurs voilà aulas et
deux sur le phare au travers alors
allons-y plus vite cela sera fait mieux
austral ne sait pas on voir monsieur du
snop salut casimir au mon cher françois
ce n'est que nous revoir et j'espère
bien me suis dit ce nom mais je monterai
dans cet avion aujourd'hui même mais oui
mais oui mais oui mais oui aller à
l'écran va et puis bruno
[Musique]
bon ben je crois que maintenant ils ne
vont plus tarder à s'envoler
je monte sur le banc je les verrai plus
facilement décoller alors françois tu as
réussi à persuader kazimi et bien une
non julie non mais je d'expliquer ce qui
s'est passé soit tu vas pas me dire que
tu l'as laissé décoller et puis le tc
tas de ferraille
ne t'inquiètes par julie t'inquiète pas
moi aussi je connais la viande mathieu
beauchesne je t'assure il est en très
bon état
bon d'accord il ya quelques pièces qui
sont un petit peu rouillé mais c'est
tout un peu rouillé et tu l'as laissé
monter là dedans tout seul justement non
monsieur du snob qui s'est passé par là
étaient enchantés de pouvoir
l'accompagner monsieur doucement mais
cette catastrophe mais c'est pas piloter
plus que lui dit il détonne oui
[Musique]
et
au malheureux lever de rideau des choses
mais carrick et là il a arrêté les
moteurs même énorme mais il tombe il va
s'écraser
et
là j'ai eu très tôt
regardez
des poètes on peut être fier de lui qu
elle même si splendides qu'elle maîtrise
de l'appareil
ça c'est vrai mais comment fait-il je ne
sais pas quelles merveilles qu'elle
maîtrise mais comment on peut dire
groupe casino
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là nous est
alors qu'aubry alors mais qui pilote
l'avion mais monsieur du snow bastia
dijon et casimir mais le pauvre homme il
ne sait pas aimer c'est justement ce qui
est drôle au bouillant dernier il fait
des pirouettes rome et c'est pas censé
foyen et sur le dos maintenant irak est
en voie de devenir quasi m'explique tout
ce qui s'est passé jetons prix fait
pourquoi ne tue pas monter dans l'avion
avec m
tu m'as dis toi même qu'il fallait être
fou pour monter les étapes ferraille
pareil au que c'est me